il s'agit peut-être d'un nouveau
rebondissement dans la sphère dils alors
que la cour de cassation vient de
décider la révision du procès de patrick
dils condamné vous le savez à perpétuité
pour le meurtre de deux enfants francis
heaulme le tueur en série aurait avoué à
ses codétenus être l'auteur du double
assassinat il avait déjà reconnu être
sur les lieux du crime mais avait
toujours nié avoir tué les enfants
les stèles mathieu philippe castillo
francis heaulme at il tué s'il est
alexandre en 1986 à montigny-lès-metz
depuis quelques heures les événements se
sont précipités
selon les informations publiées demain
dans le figaro magazine le tueur en
série déjà condamné à cinq reprises
aurait avoué le crime à ses codétenus
j'ai appris par ce client qui avait
quelque chose de très important à venir
à savoir qu'il avait savait que deal
était innocent et que l'homme était
coupable des faits pour lesquels dils
avait été condamné il lui a indiqué que
ce jour là il était sur les lieux avec
un routard d'emmaüs
il était passé devant ses enfants qui
leur avaient jeté des pierres lui était
revenue seule heaulme un homme était
revenu seul avait posé sa bicyclette
badin semble-t-il d'un talus avait gravi
un sentier et
avait retrouvé ses deux gamins je n'ai
eu aucune précision je n'ai pas demandé
d'ailleurs sur la façon dont les faits
avec mépris comme au rugby à mon client
je ne peux pas reconnaître ces faits
sinon ma soeur ne viendrait plus me voir
au parloir
contacté par téléphone m jean marc
florand l'avocat de patrick dils a
aussitôt réagi à cette déclaration que
confirmer ce que j'ai toujours fait
renoncer sévère que patrick était
parfaitement innocents du double crime
de montigné donc les révélations
capitaine francis heaulme a dit qu'on
était dont je me réjouis car
clarifieront définitivement la situation
nous permettront sans doute pas
d'obtenir rapidement tout à l'heure m
liliane glock l'avocate de francis
heaulme s'est rendu à la prison de metz
pour rencontrer son client
si l'information était vérifiée et
confirmée elle pourrait peut-être
accélérer les choses pour patrick nys
mardi dernier la cour de révision des
condamnations pénales avait ordonné la
révision de son procès patrick dils
clame son innocence depuis le début il
est en prison à toul depuis 14 ans pour
ce double meurtre il avait été condamné
à perpétuité
et dans le même temps on apprenait que
le deuxième procès de patrick dils
pourrait avoir lieu au mois de juin